la mayoría
así que al cabo estamos en occidente en
pleno siglo 21 podéis votar manifestar
os podéis estudiar
podéis trabajar vestidos como queráis
conducir
y no trata de eso la libertad de decidir
sin embargo
para mí la pregunta que importa es otra
en base a que tomáis vuestras propias
decisiones
seguramente esta mañana cuando os habéis
levantado habéis decidido libremente
como si vais a vestir verdad
no
ahora mismo si me fijo la mayoría de las
mujeres llevamos el pelo largo
algunas stamos maquilladas y otras
lleváis falda o tacón
los hombres tenéis casi todos el pelo
corto y
absolutamente todos lleváis puestos
pantalones
qué casualidad no nos habremos puesto
todas y todos de acuerdo yo no creo en
las casualidades y menos las que tienen
que ver con la libertad
cuando era pequeña volví de unas
vacaciones de navidad con un muñeco
nenuco que me habían traído los reyes
magos' resultó que todas mis amigas
habían recibido recibido el mismo regalo
que coincidencia todas con el mismo
muñeco entonces empecé a fijarme en los
detalles
os dais cuenta de que cuando una niña
salta corre y se ensucia le dicen que se
porte como una señorita cuando es un
niño el que llora le dicen que se porte
como un hombre y tanto ella como él
saben perfectamente lo que significa
portarse como una señorita y portarse
como un hombre
ellas saben que deben ser discretas y
delicadas y ellos deben ser fuertes y no
mostrar sus sentimientos
cuando a un niño con una niña empieza a
mandar
en un juego y empieza a dirigirlo
normalmente dicen que es una mandona
sin embargo cuando es un niño él te
manda dicen de él que es un líder y
todas las personas parecen estar
mágicamente de acuerdo en ello
en las fiestas de cumpleaños ocurren más
casualidades los niños suelen ir
vestidos con pantalones y hay algunas
niñas que van vestidas con vestidos y
zapatos los niños acaban trepando por
los árboles y las niñas acaban jugando a
las casitas las niñas son libres de
trepar por los árboles si quieren pero
no os voy a contar lo difícil que es
trepar un árbol vestida con un vestido
de nido de abeja y zapatos merceditas
en los patios de los colegios ocurren
más casualidades resulta que los niños
suelen ocupar el espacio central jugando
a la pelota mientras que las niñas
ocupan los laterales saltando a la comba
o hablando entre ellas las niñas son
libres de ocupar el espacio central pero
no os cuento lo rápido que los niños les
hacen ver que necesitan ese espacio para
la pelota y precisamente no de forma
diplomática
hace unos años mis amigas y yo empezamos
a tener hijas e hijos
algunas de ellas me contaban que habían
decidido reducirse la jornada o pedir
una excedencia algo que es perfectamente
legítimo y que además es un triunfo del
feminismo porque facilita la tarea de
cuidados pues bien me decían que habían
tomado esa decisión libremente
consensuada en pareja
y yo pensaba que casualidad que todas
las parejas lleguen a los mismos
acuerdos verdad
la ropa que llevamos puesto los estudios
que escogemos los trabajos a los que
aplicamos y los pactos familiares en los
que queríamos a nuestras hijas y
nuestros hijos igual no son decisiones
tan libres como pensamos
si los hombres son los que suelen ocupar
los puestos de poder y responsabilidad y
además tienen puestos de trabajo que son
mejor remunerados es porque las mujeres
hemos decidido optar a puestos peor
pagados
las feministas de la década de los 60
decían lo personal es político eso
significa que lo que le pasa a una mujer
en su casa le ocurre a todas las demás
eso significa que las decisiones que
tomamos no son tan libres como pensamos
son todo lo libres que el sistema
patriarcal nos permite que sean
la violencia machista la
infrarrepresentación femenina en los
puestos de poder el empobrecimiento
femenino no son libertad más gestionada
simbolizan precisamente esa falta de
libertad profunda y real
y todo empieza muy muy atrás antes
incluso que los zapatos merceditas y los
vestidos de nido de abeja empieza cuando
nuestros padres y nuestras madres
descubren nuestro sexo de nacimiento y
ahí empieza a construirse el género
en ese momento se toman decisiones
naturales como el color de las paredes
de tu habitación y tan trascendentales
como la educación que recibirás y los
que se esperara de ti y lo que se
esperara de ti es tan importante las
creencias y las expectativas que tenemos
las estudió el psicólogo robert rosental
en los años 60 lo llamaba el efecto
pigmalión
las expectativas y las creencias que
tenemos sobre otras personas condicionan
la forma en la que las tratamos y las
incitan a comportarse de forma en que se
confirme lo que esperamos de ellas es lo
que se conoce como profecía autocumplida
cuando esperamos que una niña sea dócil
y complaciente y esperamos que un niño
sea dominante y emocionalmente
inaccesible les estamos tratando y
alentando para que así sea para que
crean que así es como deben ser para que
piensan sienten y deciden en base a lo
que otras personas esperan
os presento a málaga málaga yusufzai
vivían pakistán en una zona donde el
régimen talibán prohíbe a las niñas
asistir a la escuela cuando tenía 11
años malala escribió un blog para la bbc
bajo seudónimo en el que denunciaba
todas estas injusticias
fue propuesta para el premio nobel de la
paz a los 15 años un hombre subía el
autobús escolar en el que iba y le
disparó tres tiros
pero málaga sobrevivió y a los 17 años
recibió el premio nobel de la paz
algo que es menos conocido en esta
historia de fortaleza ideales es el
papel que jugó su padre saudí news asia
su mentor inspiración un poeta
defensor de la educación que la educó en
el coraje y la libertad de seguir su
propia voz que la empujó para que
siguiera sus propios sueños
hoy va la la es un referente a nivel
mundial en la defensa de las niñas de la
educación dejadme que os muestro otro
ejemplo
justin crudo es el primer ministro de
canadá seguramente ya le conocéis al fin
y al cabo justin es famoso mundialmente
por haber diseñado un equipo de gobierno
paritario y diverso ha sido el primer
ministro canadiense y desfilar en la
marcha del orgullo lgtb y se ha
propuesto acabar con la brecha salarial
y ha puesto sobre la mesa la importante
relación entre el sexismo y la pobreza
muchas personas podrían pensar que todo
esto es convicción personal o incluso
una cuestión de maquillaje sin embargo
los verdaderos motivos que le llevaron a
este compromiso con la igualdad de
género los desveló el mismo días después
de resultar elegidos lo adivináis
sus padres sus padres le criaron para
ser feminista para defender y respetar
los derechos de todas las personas
la buena noticia es que la forma en la
que funciona el mundo
la hemos creado los seres humanos y los
seres humanos tenemos la capacidad de
cambiarla
estoy segura de que muchas de las
personas que estáis hoy aquí penséis que
ya estáis educando en igualdad estamos
en el siglo 21 no conocido a nadie que
me diga que educa en el machismo
sin embargo la desigualdad y la
injusticia continúan
por eso
hoy os propongo
educar a vuestras hijas e hijos niñas y
niños en libertad para ser
para ser justos valientes independientes
generosos para saber enseñarles que hay
muchas maneras de ser una niña un niño
de ser una mujer y un hombre que ellos
pueden cuidar comunicar y sentir desde
la empatía que ellas pueden liderar
proyectos triunfar en la tecnología
viajar solas pedir más
os propongo educar en la libertad de
sentir amor miedo enfado decepción
sentirlo todo y sentirlo bien empezar a
quererse a sí mismos para poder querer a
los demás
hoy os propongo educar en la libertad
para decir para decir no para decir
basta para alzar la voz y para decirlo
todo de forma inclusiva donde el
masculino genérico no ocupe todo el
campo semántico porque lo que no se
nombra no existe
os propongo educar en la libertad para
hacer
para escoger lo que les haga felices
para escoger a quien les haga felices
educar en el feminismo es educar a las
personas libres de estereotipos libres
para ser para sentir para decir aquello
en lo que creen y para hacer aquello que
quieren hacer
paulo freire dice que la educación no
cambia el mundo cambia a las personas
que van a cambiar el mundo y yo añado y
las personas que van a cambiar el mundo
serán feministas
imaginad lo está en vuestra mano educar
en el feminismo educar a las adultas y
los adultos del mañana para que sean
protagonistas de una verdadera
revolución feminista donde quepamos
todas y todos imaginad activistas por
todas partes imaginad con
responsabilidad
padres que deciden y desean quedarse en
casa cuidando de sus hijas y de sus
hijos imaginad mujeres que no tienen que
romper techos de cristal
y sufrir ningún tipo de violencia ni
discriminación de clase o racial
imaginad
la renuncia a los privilegios y
compartir los espacios imaginad que lo
tenemos todo de verdad
yo veo ese futuro
y en ese futuro no podré preguntar a la
audiencia si creen que son libres porque
educadas y educados en el feminismo
serán irrefutablemente líderes
las personas feministas no creemos en un
mundo mejor
creamos un mundo mejor y la educación es
el lugar fantástico para empezar a
hacerlo
y vosotras y vosotros como vais a educar
mañana muchas gracias
[Aplausos]